[Music]
how did this book come together tonight
my god pretty easy I actually was my
stylist Monica Rose is the most patient
person on this planet and I had a really
bad day the other day I wasn't feeling
it so you can always tell when I'm not
feeling it when I wear I just feel like
there's not much to be happy about right
now not feeling it because of the
political climate not because of you oh
no I'm not feeling it mentally
physically politically any in any way
now I feel a bit silly being here right
now that people we adore the most or at
LAX right now and John and I were
talking about being able to be there
ourselves while I'm very proud of him
and I'm proud of the movie it feels it
feels silly what is your advice to
people out there who don't know how to
get involved but but wants you and want
to make a difference I think it's very
important to donate to the ACLU I think
it's very important to just have a voice
and you need to be at those protests and
I know a lot of people think that
protests don't matter and you know
what's this gonna do but it does matter
look at SFO tonight look at JFK the
scene of it to me is actually a
beautiful and it gives me so much hope
and I think people just need to know
they can be involved and and they can
make a difference if everybody can make
a difference truly you're so wise you're
the queen of speaking up manages on a
seriously much lighter note Luna is one
of the cutest celebrity babies you
couldn't be giving her a sibling my
little boy is next for sure really I
mean I don't know but we have one oh
nice
so being your I assume with the boy
[Music]
you